Bob am i being an alarmist here that
Chuck Pagano could be in more immediate
trouble than we think well you're
talking now to a professional alarming
but I don't think it's gonna happen
unless they go out and perform the way
they did against LA when they lost what
46 to 9 and showed and showed absolutely
no fight during that game against the
Rams for a couple of reasons first
earnest a has never fired a coach in
midseason I think they you know I mean
there's always the first obviously but I
think they look at Chuck Pagano as the
bridge coach to the next guy I think
they want him to be the guy who takes
all the lumps they knew this is not
going to be a good team to start with
then you take Andrew Luck
Ryan Kelly Vontae Davis Clayton gathers
all these guys out of the equation they
know this is a bad team so unless they
go out there and absolutely quit against
the Cleveland Browns at home this Sunday
I think he's going to survive this
season and then they'll go out and get
the guy they've been walking all along
whether that's a Harbaugh Jon Gruden or
somebody else what's the latest on luck
to play in all this season well I just
rolled into the Colts facility around
12:15 Chuck Pagano will give us his
nuggets of wisdom as he always does and
I'm I'm guessing that Andrews not going
to practice today but you know we're
we're out here every day just waiting
for the the puff of smoke telling us
that Andrew Luck is going to practice at
this point even if he does practice
let's say as soon as today I can't see
him playing any sooner than a week five
I think they want to get in at least two
full uninterrupted pain-free weeks of
practice before they let him go but
here's here's what I keep telling people
in Indianapolis is that just because
luck is back doesn't mean this team is
suddenly going to be vying for the AFC
South as ordinary as that division is
your number two fee you know we remember
here 2008 Peyton Manning missed almost
all the preseason with an infected burst
on his knee and came out and really was
not very
for the first seven games and there were
three and four before he finally became
Peyton Manning against AI I wouldn't
suspect that Andrew is going to have the
kind of season that's gonna lead the
Colts back into contention in that
division but at what point is this a
redshirt season for him that you don't
put him out there because that offensive
line I don't think is markedly improved
after last year that got him in this
position in the first place
right yeah I've gotten a lot of that on
Twitter I disagree with that that idea
because look at these healthy you're
paying them a lot of money and how do
you look at all the other guys in the
rock yeah many of whom are playing with
different aches and pains and are
gutting it out and you have a
multi-million dollar franchise
quarterback sitting there who's
perfectly capable of playing and you're
saying well let's redshirt the guy you
then you're basically pooch kicking the
season you're telling the rest of your
team it doesn't matter and I think
that's a very dangerous spot for them to
put themselves in yeah but Bob were in
the era of tanking yeah well but I don't
see that happening to Colton Miller Jim
Irsay has come out you know he's come
out it's a lot of things publicly some
of which makes sense is some of which
don't but he said he doesn't have a
problem with a bad season or two if it
means multiple not a Lombardi multiple
Lombardi's down the stretch so I think
they are willing to take their lumps but
I think that I don't I don't see it
proving any point or or helping Andrew
Luck if they redshirt him this year if
he's good to go he should play football
and that way you know you go into next
season knowing you've got to help that
you hope you hope you have a healthy guy
heading into next season
Bob the Colts are underdogs and home to
the Browns I know is that unbelievable I
I have to look this up I don't think the
Browns have been a road favorites is
like I don't know 2012 or may be the
last time Dante La Valle lines up with
wide receiver I don't know
what it is but but I'm looking at their
roster and I I looked at their wide
receivers and I didn't recognize a
single name so they're not good either
this promises to be a truly ratchet
football game between two really bad
teams but if I was a betting man and I
promise you that I'm not gosh I would
take the Colts and those points because
they this isn't this is a game they
absolutely can't lose and for the guys
who are here during the Ryan Grigson era
they don't want to lose to a team that's
not only bad historically bad they don't
lose to Ryan Grigson either because
there's not a lot of warm and fuzzy
feelings in that locker room toward Ryan
Gregson so now I should mention works
for the Cleveland Browns Bob thanks for
joining us enjoy the festivities this
weekend thank you Bob
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience